we're going to let tasha have a minute
tasia adams breaks down in tears over
her split from zach clark during the
bachelorette men tell all special
there's a lot of highs and lows last
month e.t confirmed that the 31-year-old
tv personality and her fiance had called
it quits and on monday night tasia got
emotional after her co-host and fellow
former bachelorette caitlin bristow
pointed out that she was no longer
wearing her engagement ring
[Music]
yeah the ring zach gave her on the
finale of her season of the bachelorette
last year all i have to say is that i'm
heartbroken
but we tried really hard
and
i still love him very much and um
i'm not sure what the future holds
i mean you know how it is it's really
tough i sadly do know how it is and it's
really hard of course caitlyn went
through her own breakup with her
bachelorette winner and former fiance
sean booth in 2018 but she found love
again with another bachelor nation alum
jason tartick i'm just in a good place
in life and that you came into my life
at such good timing yeah where i'm just
like overall happy i'm i feel like i'm
established in things i just feel like
i'm i'm just overall happy and then i
feel like he's kind of like a bonus to
me because
i won't get emotional but he's like the
best person i've ever met and the two
got engaged back in may
caitlin
girl let me see that ring i know oh my
gosh i've been staring at it all day now
back to tasia we're here for you and
obviously want you to be happy thank you
but the tears didn't stop there after
inviting rodney a former contestant on
michelle young's season of the
bachelorette to the stage tasia
continued to cry before getting up and
walking off without saying a word
we're gonna let tasha have a minute
after pulling herself together the
reality star returned for the next
segment you know
it's tough e.t was with tasia just weeks
before news of her breakup with zach
went public harry and zach we're great
thank you new york has been amazing and
we're having fun out there and while she
stayed pretty tight-lipped about her
relationship she did weigh in on
co-hosting the bachelorette with caitlin
and if she's down to return for more
starting night one we get down and dirty
we really
try to take a different look and
approach to these guys can we see you
two again on the next season of
bachelorette what's the stat i mean
maybe
fingers crossed we'll see